30 minute workouts 20 minute recipes 10
minute mindfulness ready to become
get fill on the app store or Google Play
hi everyone it's Joanna here welcome
back to another workout series with our
field trainers and today we have Marco
in the house so be ready for another
killer kickboxing session yes so today
we're going to do five rounds we're
going to go on Technique we are going to
do some Mobility we are going to do some
endurance power and we're going to work
out at the core as well so we're going
to throw some punches some kicks and
we're going to sweat together you ready
yes so I'm ready to throw some punches
at kicks let's do this let's do it
okay guys let's get ready for this
workout 45 seconds in 15 seconds out
we're going to do five rounds and let's
start with the warm-up so let's start
here just rolling your hands slightly
relax your arms relax your legs we're
going to just maintain a bit of movement
John is getting ready as well
let's do some shuffles move your feet
back and forth that's it coordination on
your hands and feet
good job
I'm going to work out in some lower body
today
let's do some squats set your feet
pointing to the front let's go with the
squats all the way here activation on
your glutes
we're going to work in some pulses ready
pulsing down five
four
three
two and one Shake It Off
now we're going to start with some
Plyometrics we're going to do some
jumpings we Comfort them for the squat
jump one jump two jump three shake it up
again good job there's a few movements
that we're going to use we're going to
do some reverse lunges activation on
your glutes as well on your legs one on
the right one on the left
that's it
three
two
and one good job let's keep the rope
we're going to your simulator we're
skipping group
you can play here with any movement on
your legs with a bit of rotation on your
shoulders as feel your as much as you
just feel comfortable with your roll
that's it
we're getting ready we're getting ready
let's go now for a bit of a speed fit in
three two and let's go moving faster
faster faster on your spot three two and
one good job we're ready we're almost
about to start we have 20 more seconds
and what we're going to do minute one 45
seconds we're going to just start easy
with our combination we're going to do
jab cross and we're going to bring the
right knee up okay reset your position
jab cross right knee second minute we're
going to switch for another combination
okay you ready Joanna yes I am perfect
so boxing standing and let's get ready
with jab cross and riding in three two
let's go jab cross right knee Mountain
you're bouncing one two right knee good
job this first round is just for your
Technique you just need to feel
comfortable in your space
moving around jab cross right knee
remember jab cross your right hand makes
balance makes power in your knee one two
right knee up get back one two right up
and down one hand will be protecting
your face all the time good job
boom get back one two right knee we have
five more seconds one two right knee and
last one good job Shake It Off
it's super simple now let's go out now
with the left knee so we're going to
switch the up cross we're going to do
one extra jab and we're going to come
with the left knee and with a bit get
back okay jab cross jab and left knee
ready three two go one two three left
knee get back one two three left knee
and get back nice steps there
we're going to switch your legs here one
two three switch legs left knee up and
bring it down one two three boom
yeah one two three boom
this round just feel comfortable one two
three moving to the left get back
whenever you feel any any tightness you
can start like a juice bounce in here
whenever you feel we go again
boom three punches one e one two three
and one good job 15 seconds now we can
use this 15 seconds as an active
recovery you can keep moving or you can
just be in a bit of rest so if you feel
it you can use that as well okay let's
get ready now we're going to add the
block on the right leg ready one two
right knee and we block one more time
right two block I miss a knee ah yes one
two right knee and block good job one
two knee and block good job yeah
now we're working as well in your core
oh
[Music]
yeah
one more time right knee right block
good job one two right knee right block
one two right knee right block and one
more time right knee
one block and Shake It Up we have 15
seconds recovery now we're going to do
it on the left jab cross jab left knee
and left block okay
I hope my left knee is much better than
the right
let's get ready three two let's go jab
cross jump left knee left block reset
your feet and one more time
left knee left block
good job 30 seconds more here one two
three left knee block all the time one
two three
forward side good job reset one two
three knee and block
one two three knee and block good job
you can increase your speed anytime you
can increase your power anytime you're
still comfortable first
with your Technique that's it Shake It
Out 15 seconds now we're going to work
out in both sides hands up in a boxing
and standing we're going to go in a
block on the right block on the left
okay ready for some workout on your core
three two hands up let's go right
bouncing left bouncing right good job
this is a
slow pace here you want to challenge
yourself you want to make it slightly
more harder you can do one and one
bouncing here so we can use both options
whenever you feel tired as well from
this one just like a one two up one two
up that's it what option do you want for
the last 15 seconds you are let's go
yeah let's go speed all together let's
go for Speed right and left
traction on your core
four more seconds three
two
and one good job first one is done and
now we have all the power on our body
we're warm up properly and now we're
going to do some mobility and for this
we're going to work out on your squats
so what we're going to do jab cross
we're going to put your feet together
and we're going to do one jump reset
your standing jab cross legs together
and jump okay minute one we go for one
jump minute two two minute three and
we're going to switch later on ready
let's go jab cross and one jump get back
jab cross switch jump
one two
boom
switch your legs
that's it we need to feel that we pivot
on your left leg okay switch one two
one get back one two pivot jump
one two straight up
one two
good job
five more seconds
let's go for the last one
and 15 seconds recovery now round number
two what do we do two two jumps
let's get ready Shake It Up you remember
your 15 seconds is active recovery or
just a simple resting okay three two
hands up one two two jumps one two let's
get back one two
one
two that's it
one and two
one two switch one
two
yeah filling it up
one two
one
two get back yes
Mobility for your legs a little bit open
endurance as well
you will fill it on your quad
one
two and Shake It Up 15 seconds
round number three this is getting
tougher now let's go for three Shake It
Off let's bring up the heat
oh and get on let's get ready three
two
let's go jab cross and now one
two
three switch back one two and one
two
three good job
also your option whenever you feel just
get down into your normal squat also
also allowed
take a bit of break whenever you fill it
with your normal Squat and then keep
back Jumping
foreign
[Music]
get back 10 seconds more
one
two three we have one more one two three
good job Shake It Off
relax your legs feeling your quads oh
yeah everything else let's go for
isometrical move here we're going to
hold your squat we're going to do 10
punches and one jump ready three two
down one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten jump come down again one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten jump
feeling on the quad
10 jump
good job
almost there
four five six seven eight nine ten jump
almost one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten one more good job Shake
It Up
for the final one this is going to be
more Dynamic we're going to shuffle
punches we're going to relax a bit your
legs okay three
two
and just coordination between hands and
legs good job back and forth one hand
punch one hand covers your face
this feel like I'm relaxing after the
after the the holding and the jumpings
good job
then you read him here
15 seconds
almost there
five more seconds
three
two
and we have 30 seconds of break well
goodwana all good feeling it yes cool
two rounds the idea
now let's get ready here we're going to
work out on the right side first and
then on the left standing position we're
going to do jab cross and we're going to
do one reverse lunge we're going to do
three pulses one two three stand jab
cross and we go to the right three
pulses okay
let's get ready three two and go chop
cross reverse launch one two three back
jab cross back two three reset one two
one two three get back that's it
foreign
legs that's what we want
a lot of sweat a nice power good job
[Music]
good job good job
one two one two three one two and
recover 20 15 seconds
good job now we're going to hold on the
right side we're going to hold your
squat at your launch we're going to
three hooks reset ready
let's go for it
killing the right side let's go holding
one
two
three hooks stand relax if you need and
one more time down one
two three get back Shake It Off and one
more time one
two three get back back one
two three get back
good job
your challenge now is to maintain your
left leg totally stable we don't move
anymore you're left good job left hand
protect your face as well we punch on
the right side only
one more and one two three reset Shake
It Off
now we're done on the left on the right
side let's go on the left same thing jab
cross reverse on the left with triple
pulsing ready
five seconds to go
time to work out on the left three two
one jab cross reverse one two three step
forward jab cross reverse one two three
good job
foreign
this is a coordination between your legs
your position and your hands
good job
I'm feeling the burn it is now yeah
now it's time for our left side
now the right feeling even relax
last one one more
and that's it 15 seconds almost at
almost there
we're going to do it now holding your
reverse launch on the left and we're
going to do the three hooks okay three
two and let's go back and one
two
three stand back and one two three stand
good job
we're trying to don't move your right
leg we're just moving your left back one
two three back that's it
this is helping us to have a nice
ability on your side one two three bring
it back down one two three good job 15
seconds and now as we did last round
we're going to relax a bit so we're
going to go with power knees okay right
and left
now relaxing for your quad only Power
needs three two let's go right left
right left good job
inhale from your nose exhale from your
mouth this this is filling now a bit
relaxing now we are just relaxing your
legs after the workout we did
that's it
it's a type of active recovery what
we're doing but still feeling the
workout
15 more seconds
almost there almost there that's five
three
two
and last one 30 seconds good job
all good yeah more than halfway yeah
cool
now we're going to work out
what again on the right side so the
first one what we're going to do hands
up River Side launch and we are coming
with the up knee up and from here we go
down we come up again we're working on
air stability your left leg we try to
don't move okay let's go on the right
side three
two let's go right
bring your knee up balance right again
balance good job
you can have the option
go up down step and then we can do again
okay up to you whatever option you want
you want to challenge yourself
you can go for this one or you can have
a little bit of break stepping down on
your right leg again ready
[Music]
10 more seconds
five more
three
two
and one fifteen seconds now we're going
to do one squat we're going to do a kick
to the front on the right same thing
still moving only your right side
standing on your left ready
three two let's go down squat kick down
squat kick
good job
this works on your kicks this works on
your core works on your
builds as well good job
your left hand is not moving from
protecting your face your right hand is
making the balance here to feel the kick
that's it
10 more seconds
good job
five more
three
two
and one good job
right side already going for this let's
go to the left we move to the side
lunges to the left with your knee up
ready remember your options you go all
the way straight or you can have a rest
here and do it again ready let's go left
knee
left knee good job
by this time come on you just need to go
with those guys
let's do it
look at that balance
good job good job
your right leg stable left leg bring it
up feel the contraction in your in your
core here you will feel a little bit of
crunchy so this is what we want to make
a nice contraction here on your core
abdominals working
and your legs as well
three
two
and one fifteen seconds
we are totally warm up
let's go for now the squat and the kicks
on the left side ready we have still
five seconds
all good yes all good perfect let's go
one more set three two go down and now
the kick on the left right hand always
will protect your face your left hand
will make the nice swing for your kick
30 more seconds
almost there
[Music]
good job 10 seconds more and we're going
to work on your core
three
two and one shake it off now what we're
going to do position your position and
from here we're going to split your legs
we cross right to left left to right
ready Shake It Off
working on your abdominals in three two
let's go right back left back
good job challenge try to step always in
the same spot
make a nice crunch
and reset your feet to step in the same
spot good job
there's one we don't need to rush we
just need to ensure that we feel that
crunch between your arm and your legs
elbow to knee
all the way here
10 more seconds
good job good job
we have three
two
and one good job we have 30 more seconds
of break and now we have the last one
are you guys ready for a finisher I am
ready go for three power knees one two
three one Squat and we switch to three
knees on the left one squat okay second
minute we're going to do ten mountain
climbers and one sprawled so we do ten
legs together jump in jump out for the
second and fourth minute ready three two
let's go right right right
squat left left
squat good job
one two three down one two three down
good job
20 more seconds
[Music]
one two three down that's it keep it up
10 more seconds
and 15 seconds recovery let's go for now
for 10 mountain climbers and one is pro
ready
plank position 10 mountain climbers one
is pro and we're going three
two
and let's go one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten in out one more
time
three four five six seven eight nine ten
jump in jump out
good job
in jump out one two three four five
seven eight nine ten jump in jump up ten
more seconds
yo man jump out one two three four five
seven eight nine ten jump in jump out
and 15 seconds recovery good job
what about if we challenge a bit more
the last one let's go with the power
knees butt jumping okay let's do this
and jump Squat and jump squat okay here
you go okay ready go one two three jump
one two three jump
foreign
this is the finisher
oh
almost there
one two three jump
one two three yeah
last one one more two three last jump
good job
that was fun
you can feel it let's go for one more 10
mountain climbers and one sprawl
let's get ready three
two
let's go one two three four five seven
eight nine ten jump in jump out
four five six seven nine ten jump in
jump out
jump in jump out good job
jump in jump out 20 more seconds
jump in jump out one two three four six
seven eight ten in out one two three
four four seven eight nine ten last in
last out good job
we have one more and
what about we've just finished with what
about the Barbie oh my gosh your
favorite let's do it it's ready ten
push-up plaques oh sorry plant Jacks and
one Barbie three two plank position and
let's go one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten or B let's go down
again and one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten down and burpee
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten down
that last one faster
six seven eight nine last morphine
good job oh my god well done well done
that was a killer oh my gosh
how do you feel it amazing feel the legs
working on the core we had some
technique as well some knees so let's
get ready now for a cool down and we are
set to go so let's get somewhere from
down inhale
[Music]
and stretch your hands on your toes
feeling the stretching on your calves
three
two
and one we're going to open your compass
we're going to slide your hands to your
heels five
four
three
two and one we go to the right
five
four
three
two and one we move left
five
four
three
two and one hands down on the ground
five
four
three
two and one and from here we're going to
work your feet together we're going to
catch your toes we're going to drop your
hips in a deep squat we're going to open
up your hips with your elbows under in
in between of your legs five
four three two and one we're going to
stretch your hips up feeling on your
hamstrings five
four
three
two and one we're going to get somewhere
from down inhale and exhale let's see if
we have balance bring your knee up pull
your knee high five
four
three
two and one from here let's pass your
leg to the back catch it up
squat
stretching five
four
three
two and one let's switch to the left
bring it up
five
four
three
two and one bring your hand leg back
and what's stretching five
four
three
two and one we are going to walk your
hands slightly to the front and we're
going to just put your hips back into a
down dog five
four
three
two and one is lightly bringing your
chest down and chest up for your up dog
three
two and one from your plank your right
hand to your left toes to stretch a bit
your
your core three
two and one on the left side three
two and one
walk your plank back
got somewhere from down inhale
and exhale and let's go for the last one
inhale
and bring your hands down good job oh my
God thank you so much Marco that was
amazing honestly I was just trying to
keep up with you but I had a really good
sweat let me know how you guys felt at
home okay and if you enjoyed this video
then be sure to check out a lot more
kickboxing workouts with Marco on the
field app download it for free on the
App Store or Google play or go and check
out our website fieldlife.com Marco
thank you so much guys don't forget to
also subscribe to my YouTube channel for
a lot more workout videos healthy
recipes as well as fitness tips and if
you enjoyed this workout with Marco let
me know in the comments below because
I will bring Marco back okay thank you
amazing